bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenute
questo nuovo video io sono felice oggi
siamo su e mondi tewsley praga slip e un
videogame che sospettando tantissimo da
da un bel po di tempo proprio da mesi e
dovrebbe uscire questa è una fa non è la
versione ufficiale soltanto l'alfa
dovrebbe uscire non lo so più avanti
comunque lo farò di sicuro perché mi
aveva preso tantissimo perché avevo
visto il tracollo mesi fa quindi sarà
veramente fantastico ed è uscita verserà
fa quindi non vedo l'ora di provarla ai
autoplay al baraka che i ragazzi siano
stiamo partendo non ti prendo lara
dividendo evidenti ma chissà cantucci
qui sotto ok basta
lei sa che tar dice la porta semi aperta
guardate che ambientazione fantastica
l'ideale per farci dormire un bambino un
bio bio
c'è la porta semiaperta c'è tipo nei
film horror che io brega paranormal
orsacchiotto fermate
fermati due vai mi servi dove vai se non
riesco a dormire dove vai
non ci fu ma cazzo ragazzi emo dio
succede ci sono i video no no no la
porta semiaperta non riesco a dormire al
buio maledetto orsacchiotto piazza dove
maps ancora ragazzo si sta muovendo la
culla e la casa telecom andarci incastro
perfetto siamo ci siamo schiantati sono
vivo
sono vivo buongiorno nessuno ragazzi non
enormi perché mi si è cappottata la
ragazza voglio capire come cazzo ha
fatto a muoversi la cool annuncia le
rotelle di sotto com'è possibile
sto gattonando perché frega ragiona cosa
incredible già no questo è quello
dell'era glaciale lo voglio che voglio
manny vieni qua il mammut dopo dovrei
lasciato sud dove chi mi serve maledetto
dai anche l'etichetta lara gut troppo
epico e cosa che mi serve starò fragile
fragile un cazzo il resto salgo su tutto
e spacco tutto perché sono un bambino di
due anni e posso fare quello che voglio
c'è una porta non ci arrivo perché non
ci si poteva alzare in piedi mi pare in
qualche modo mio di cellophane grande
adesso so tre anni con la omogenizzato
sono cresciuto in 3 secondi e mi serve
cosa faccio mi sto trattando la pancia
non è normale non ci arrivo comunque
come faccio cioè non è che devo saltare
tipo o che aspettate un attimo forse è
grande questo non è un bambino cazzo è
tipo spider man si arrampichi comunque
vice alta no
come faccio devo a sipos firma barca
[ __ ] che ne so io spingiamo tutto ci
dovremmo essere stava aspettate vedere
se ci arrivo
ok ci siamo mamma mia che genio sono un
bambino di due anni ma mio dio
einstein non è un cazzo in confronto a
me cosa devo fare qui posso di tornare a
gattonare che la festa è si può
era figlio gattonare mi diverte di più
alla ragazzi c'è qualcosa qui la
lavanderia bene è accesa la lavatrice
c'è l'armadio semi aperto l'armadio semi
aperto ragazzi non è normale sta cosa
gli armadi semi aperti non mi piacciono
devo riuscire a c'è nessuno qui dentro
no
ok no perché gli armadi semi aperti
negli horror non è mai nulla di buono
perché c'è la partita è qui che il
calcio tv aprì a che cosa c'è dentro
perché stava girando stati ce l'ha presa
da colio stocco la presa perché sono un
bambino cattivo
ok va bene ci siamo ragazzi sono si apre
per il dialetto di entrare nella
lavatrice brutto stronzo la mamma si
arrabbierà ok ok ha ritrovato benissimo
6 tutto bagnato ma ti devo abbracciare
perché sono un bambino cattivo e quindi
mi voglio bagnare il pigiama ragazzi c'è
qualcosa qui non so che cos'è sta roba
ma io uscirei di qua ho trovato un
orsacchiotto già qualcosa
no quella mia ombra inquietantissimo c'è
ma dopo sofferenza che oggi si è aperta
lo zio si sono aperte le scale non è
normale sa cosa è permesso
io io scendo io scendo giù perché si
sono permesse la palla la palla me la
porto però la palla me la porto
concedetemi la palla ok vai così grande
la palla è mia amica vai vai controllare
che non c'è nessuno vai vai e vai è
libero di miss a libero dimmi se c'è
qualcuno va il primato già una palla nei
meandri delle tenebre perché possa
morire prima di tutti c'è qualcun agazzi
c'è qualcuno in casa però non so chi
perché sta aprendo le porte a caso sia
si apre grande
devo cos'è c'è un pesticida cos'è sta
roba
alzati alzati tutto uomo gigante cos'è è
un estintore sono alto questo un
estintore benissimo cosa devo fare
fatemi scavalcano dimentico che sono un
bambino e posso strisciare cos'è questo
cos'è sta roba qui è un clistere un mio
più cos'è ok bene c'è stato un tuono
assurdo ma cos'era della televisione
benissimo io voglio mettere che alcun
network datemi il telecomando
voglio vedere che alcun network e
mangiando cos'è cereali se lo pretendo
perché sono un bambino cattivo non mi
piace questo cartone io voglio nel cane
fifone
io devo restano comprendono benissimo
ragazzi è fatto da chi c'è lì la la
permesso la casa sarebbe mia quindi devo
entrare ragazzi non è che cosa sta
succedendo ho visto delle arance chi è
che si sta sbriciolando il prego io so
io a tardi io c'ho na banana qualsiasi
possono studio c'è una banana
c'è anche una mela volendo c'è tutto e
cos'è sta roba qui cos'è e del cibo in
scatola viola lancio dalla finestra ma
non si erano piano edizione va bene ho
trovato del cibo in scatola banane e io
io mi fido
cos'era quell'ombra a sono io porca
[ __ ]
mi son preso malissimo sia siamo né
chi cazzo è che sta facendo sto casino
spiegatemelo ragazza diventa cioè mio
zaino c'è il mio zaino di scorno con non
è uno zaino un orsacchiotto questo cosa
è stato anche bello che 66 fantastiche
ti porterò con me ti chiamerò pif
no non ti chiamerò pif chiamerò in
qualsiasi altro modo ma non pf e devo
andare avanti ragazzi c'è una porta
chiusa io dovevo aprirla non si può
aprire poi ha sì si può aprirci arrivo
in questa non ci arrivo ragazzi agli
occhi fu dammi la mano chi serve do aprì
la porta
spostiamo la sedia di prepotenza raga
sta diventando veramente è già in che
tantissime che sta diventando c'è il
telefono c'è il telefono mai che chiama
la mamma abbia [ __ ] al telefono
capito non importa andiamo avanti
devo riuscire a pesta maledettissima
porta e non è normale comunque come
gioco perché ci sono riuscito apriamo
stava le detta porta andiamo vedere cosa
c'e di qua
c'era qualcuno comunque in cucina e
classi a in qualsiasi posto sia andato è
di sicuro di qua perché non c'è nessun
altro posto permesso c'è nessuno sta
diventando che queste sono le mie scarpe
cosa devo devo andare avanti ragazzi
devo andar avanti qua c'è un altro porto
raga non so dove
non so come proseguire e chico scusate
c'è un'altra stima perché tengono gli
estintori nell'armadio non è normale sta
cosa va beh noi ragazzi sta diventando a
suo di moby cosa ci fai qua perché pif
non sei rimasto in cucina mi servi per
teorico a te
una scopa una maledettissima scopa
maledetta stronza che mi fai prendere
colpi va bene la ragazzi le scope sono
nostre nemiche
da adesso in avanti ci sono porte semi
aperte io veramente raga nelle porte
semiaperte sono quelle dove non andrei
perché c'era qualcuno quindi presumo
abbia aperto le porte lui quindi non ci
vorrei andare ma io ho beef fip
proteggimi serve qualcuno che mi
protegga non è un caso ragazzi qua non
vedo nulla perché è una luce minima una
luce qualsiasi c'è non vedo niente
non è un caso a chi è perfetto ma c'è
qualcosa o non vedi questa stanza
completamente buia quindi non se c'era
qualcosa da prendere non l'ho presa
perché non si vede una mazza beh io
chiudo qui per sicurezza perché non
vorrei mai che mi spuntasse qualcuna
bene allora dove sono finiti adesso c'è
una scrivania c'è mica il computer che
logo su facebook e chiede aiuto se non
perfetto d'arredo salirci il cassetto se
non va bene
grande ragazzi questo bambino è una cosa
impressionante cioè che omogenizzati si
piglia al giorno d'oggi c'è una cosa
impressionante
forse la devo costruire mitico una scala
con le cose che trovo di sotto
sempre se riescono a aspettate un attimo
by ok raga non ci riesco a liszt ci
arriva la porta ma che si può vedere
cosa c'è di qua c'è sotto le coperte
sì sì sono l'ho visto che si sono mosse
raga non è normale ma voglio più entrare
più dentro prima volevo entrarci ma ora
non c'entro più ma l'inter come faccio
ad opere la maniglia ma non ci tengo più
tanto adesso
ok questo e per dora l'esploratrice lo
faccio per te ce l'ho fatta grandi ed
ora che mi dà la forza di fare le cose
te buon già permesso agli di brutto
stronzo
ce la posso fare alla ragazzi c'è
qualcuno sul letto visto che si muoveva
visto che si muoveva perché io devo
salire sullo scudetto
che brutta cosa se senti ho visto
qualcuno che si muoveva la mamma sei tu
chi c'è nessuno che sapete cos'è non
c'era nessuno vi prendete per il culo
non c'era nessun o mio dio
oh mio dio aiuta chi c'è qualcuno ha
aperto la porta ma l'ha fatto in un modo
troppo marca però io io io arrivo si
buongiorno mi che nessuno sarà un
bambino che gioca la mamma non fatemi
del marsec non era già sapete che cosa è
stato stupido che in quel senso più che
altro praticamente è cosa si immaginano
i bambini quando tipo hanno paura o
rimangono al buio cioè perché comunque
tutti abbiamo avuto favore del genere la
picco di tipo porte che si aprono ma qua
non ce l'ho già passato si allora che
cazzo ci faccio qui ci hanno già passato
vabbè allora torniamo indietro anche se
non ho capito bene che cosa sto andando
a fare perche i
porsche ha visto cagato addosso
cos'è la quella roba ovvio questo è
peggio dello splendor me il mio zio è
una figura bruttissima bene io voglio un
covo è bene altro che porto se sei qua
c'è una luce ragazza c'è una luce c'è
una luce che non ho visto prima mio zio
è una base fantastico c'è una bici io me
ne andrei quaid cos'è sta roba
cos'è ben sicurezza prima di entrare ci
lancia il cubo al cubo di miss è sicuro
dopo sei vivo chicca meno a perfetto
grazie mille miglia sono ci sarei
entrato bongio permesso mio cazzo siamo
bene fantastico questo non è normale cor
caputa può arrivare a l'immaginazione
dei bambini
non ne ho idea spero che sia immaginate
gradi grazie mille curve senza di te
luce avrei mai fatta e dove si sa cos'è
questo cos'è cos'è sta roba
ok dove sono finito mio dio ed è sparito
tutto
ragazzi siamo stiamo siamo in garage
credo si sta cos'è sta roba ci sono i
maghi e mattoni via devo passare ex
sesto posto ma che cazzo maligno riesco
a passare
ok perfetto ci siamo ci sono dei tavoli
attaccati al muro nel canzoncina che
arriva di qua
che figo ragazzi un grammofono credo sia
meglio c'è dentro dentro
non so se devo figli amici dentro si
solamente ma io mi citò fa mai cos'è ok
oh mio dio
cos'è a questa è la fia ragazzi ci siamo
questa è la fine
deve essere il trailer finale no vi
giuro è stato un qualcosa di fantastico
no io io giocherò di sicuro ma ma di
sicuro quando uscirà la versione
ufficiale la giocherò ma proprio senza
dubbio perché questo forse lo
rappresento uno dei migliori videogame
horror del 2013 di sicuro che usciremo
meno male che non ho incontrato ste cose
vabbè laga io direi di chiudere qui
l'episodio sei comunque video vi è
piaciuto lasciato argomento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come in
ogni video trovate nella descrizione a 7
per i siti iscrivetevi invece vediamo
nel prossimo video bene ragazzi